Jeremy Corbyn was in Kazakh today but he
was supposed to be in the rather more
exotic Ghana next week on an official
visit that's been cancelled because
instead he wants parliamentarians to
come together and have an emergency
summit to avert an Odile brexit he'd
written two party leaders inviting them
to meet within days all of the
opposition parties will be there and
we'll discuss the process by which we'll
put forward a motion of no confidence
and others will bring up other
suggestions including the legislative
proposal but we'll be having a serious
discussion next week this build on
Corbin's overtures last week where he
asked other parties to vote against
Boris Johnson in a motion of no
confidence and install him as Prime
Minister to extend article 50 and have
an election Lib Dem leader Joe Swenson
described it as a nonsense her party
says she will attend but they're still
skeptical I hope that Jeremy Corbyn if
he realizes and certainly the numbers
are against him already that he could
not form that coalition government or
that alternative government that he'd be
willing to allow someone else to step in
indeed no sooner had the proposal been
put out that it had been rejected by
independent MP and former Tory Nick
Bowles writing to Corbin I do not
believe that your proposal is workable I
for one will not support a motion of
no-confidence while the Johnson
government continues to pursue a brexit
deal that might deliver an orderly
brexit from the EU nor would I be able
to support any government in which you
were Prime Minister however temporary
its mandate several other MPs sitting on
the opposition benches have said the
same some have suggested that Corbin
cannot even command MPs on the Labour
benches indeed there are whispers about
them breaking ranks if Corbin cannot get
support to form a new administration but
the truth is his internal critics are
willing to give him a chance to try I
think we should have been back in
Westminster this week actually but I
think what needs to happen now is we all
need to be getting around the table
those of us in Parliament who absolutely
will not tolerate a No Deal breaks it
and that is the majority and we need to
find a way no matter what to get
somewhere with that that instinctive
loyalty is a problem for those other MPs
who was just stopped No Deal but don't
wish to pay the price of Jeremy Corbyn
to get it the ante no dealers want
Corbin to give them
riffing the vote for an alternative
administration the votes to compel Boris
Johnson to extend article 15 whilst they
offer him nothing in return yeah as they
never fail to point out Jeremy Corbyn
cares about Europe much less than they
do given that he has the parliamentary
numbers and that fact why from Corbin's
point of view he says should he give in
and compromise when they won't so much
of brexit right now feels like managing
the blame and anger of the remain as
when it all goes wrong if neither side
budgets convinced the other must there
will be a lot to go around
Louis choral Sky News Westminster